[Musique]
francis carole bonjour bonjour à vous et
bonjour à celles et à ceux qui nous font
l'amitié de nous regarder de nous
écouter vos lui vous êtes conseiller
territorial candidats aux élections
législatives sur la circonscription de
fort de france pour la liste du grand
ensemble et pour matinik alors qu'est ce
qui motive votre candidature
d'abord parce que je pense que l'action
que nous menons mardi que je mène
personnellement depuis des décennies a
besoin d'un prolongement au parlement
français singulièrement la semaine à
cela parce que nous sommes limités dans
nos possibilités et dia un certain
nombre de décisions à prendre qui doit
passer par la loi qui doit passer par
l'assemblée nationale et après aussi
d'un alors il s'agit il s'agit
particulièrement à mon avis de
l'ensemble de questions d'abord tout ce
qui touche et à un foisonnement de notre
peuple et au chlordécone parce que cette
question est essentielle il ya bien
entendu une grande manifestation le 28
mai mais il faut une action législative
sur cette question notamment vous parler
du non lieu
qui menacent même si dans séparation de
la justice et deux de l'action politique
du sida et de l'ulis natif mais il ya
quand même nécessité de poser sa tête et
surtout le faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une loi d'indemnisation qui soit voté et
qui concerne tout le champ des désastres
à la fois humain économique créée par
l'utilisation du chlordécone en
organique et puis il ya bien entendu
d'autres questions de questions qui
touchent à l'éducation je pense qu'il
faut aujourd'hui aux marocains une
manière de cogestion de l'éducation
nationale notamment en matière de pau
tenu des programmes pour la réussite de
nos élèves dans un contexte où
finalement la question de la réussite
d'une question centrale et puis
concernant les questions de santé bien
tout le monde s'est plaint un peu de la
manière dont la crise a été gérée alors
il faut poursuivre la modernisation des
obtient ce que nous avons fait par
exemple avec et l'effort et que nous
avons consentis pour pouvoir mettre à
plat ce cyclotron avec l'équipe d'alfred
marie jeanne mais il faut aller au delà
il nous faut une congestion du système
de santé parce que nous finançons la
santé et parce qu'aussi nous sommes les
mieux placés pour savoir ce qui convient
à notre pays et je pense que lorsqu'il
n'ya par exemple une crise il faut que
nous soyons en état de cause de cette
crise nous n'avons pas à atteindre est
une désir de paris pourrait décider de
lever ou pas des décisions et de
confinement et autres donc je pense que
la gestion doit être partagé et qu'une
collectivité comme la collectivité
martinez doit pas être une collectivité
secondaire dans l'aude et dans des
décisions qui concernent la santé des
martiniquais des martiniquaises alors
plus particulièrement sur la
circonscription de fer de france sur
laquelle vous vous vous présentez
qu'elles sont là les les priorités selon
vous qui sont lesquels il faudra pencher
si vous devez vous venez à être élu à
l'assemblée nationale alors une question
qui touche à la fois la population de
foleux fois cette fouille à l'aise et
faut y aller mais toute la mort fait que
c'est la question de la vie chère et
cette question de la vie chère et à
l'urgente à dire que que certains
sautent à ce que de négocier mille
produits et je rappelle que en 2009 nous
demandions la baisse de 100 produits et
nous avons eu du mal à l'obtenir donc il
faut passer par la loi c'est pas la 7e
c'est la loi c'est à dire cela
ressemblait à saunal pour plusieurs
choses d'abord il faut bloquer les prix
pas d'un moment parce que c'est très
important notamment les prix des
produits dont les martiniquais ont le
plus besoin deuxièmement il faut aussi
fait en sorte que et court instant une
commission de contrôle des prix parce
qu'il ya manifestement de l'abus il faut
intervenir aussi sur sûre et la tva mais
sur ces produits et puis évidemment on
peut voir aussi un certain nombre de
modulation concernant certains produits
est payé pour
la taxe qui est demandée en martinique
pour l'octroi de mer bon mais très
secondairement et je pense que ce sont
des mesures qu'il faut prendre ces
mesures doivent être prises à
l'assemblée nationale c'est le rôle de
l'assemblée nationale de prendre ces
mesures et je crois que c'était pas
autant parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut le
dire il y a des gens qui ne mangent pas
à leur faim martinique il ya des gens
qui ne peuvent plus acheter un bidon de
gaz il y à cette misère qui explique des
eaux beaucoup de dérives et soul et
justement c'est bien qu'elle arrive nous
vont réagir vous parler de dérive ça
amène à la question allez vous poser
fort de france est effectivement et la
cire contre circonscription de
martinique la plus frappée par la
criminalité c'est la criminalité bien
une conséquence de la détresse sociale
la commune et halte est une conséquence
de la dédicace économique de la détresse
sociale de la détresse culturel aussi
très important de le dire c'est à dire
que les hommes ne faut pas que hbo a
imagé ils ont besoin aussi d'être
respectés et je crois qu'il ya un
système qui pousse à ses ex et il faut
par conséquent mais je le dis depuis
longtemps qu'elle longtemps je dis et je
j'avais prédit que inévitablement sinon
on ne naît pas une lutte conséquente
contre la criminalité et bien nous
aurions les dérives que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui on tue pour une raison au
point mais il faut en même temps changer
le modèle économique de sorte que nos
jeunes puissent trouver le moyen de
s'épanouir de se développer et si on ne
change pas ce modèle économique si on
reste dans l'économie de plantation si
on est dedans cette espèce de société
parce esclavagistes qui ne dit pas son
nom eh bien on discute et de discuter
faut aller vers la modernisation il faut
aller aussi un vrai développement
martinique a alors brièvement qu'avez
vous à dire aux électeurs alors chers
compatriotes et de fort-de-france et
fo est à l'aise vous y allez cette
victoire peut-être emporté ensemble je
crois que nous avons un programme que
nous avons diffusé vous connaissez mon
action sur le terrain au plus près des
gens je suis non seulement un homme de
dossiers un homme de terrain de
proximité nous pouvons gagner cette
bataille mais le plus important c'est
que chaque électrices chaque électeur
sorte le 11 juin à éviter si nous avons
voté massivement nous gagnons si très
peu de gens se déplacent ce sera
extrêmement compliqué parce que le ppm à
9000 voix en général en douce ce sont
des gens qui sont connus qui sont
activés à chaque fois qu'il ya des
élections même si je respecte ces gens
mais je dis que lorsqu'on a plus de
soixante mille électeurs dans une
circonscription comme un autre il faut
aller voter donc je compte sur vous je
vous fais confiance pour vous déplacer
massivement le 11 juin le samedi 11 juin
avec le soutien de vote francis carole
christelle ça moi je compte sur vous
francis carole merci à vous
[Musique]